just want to go home to my kids I get it
this is crazy
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by cardi B she's a
Grammy award-winning artist with more
number one singles than any other woman
in hip-hop history and she has yet
another record climbing the charts as we
speak it's called Bongos alongside Megan
the stallion as to be expected in
Immaculate music video to match check it
out but first cardi B welcome to the
show hey
what's going through your head as you
prepare to take on The Gauntlet are you
nervous at all are you naturally a hot
sauce person I'm I'm nervous because
it's like I'm setting myself up to have
diarrhea so it's like I like know what's
gonna happen like later on but this is
worth this is worth it though it's worth
it because I'm telling you like my fans
been begging me to do this show for so
so so so so long
I have to give it to them and I'm so
scared oh my gosh
foreign
[Music]
she's cute
she's cute I don't know
[Music]
I like her
so I want to congratulate you on a
Flawless rollout for bongo's great song
Ace the video bodied the performance at
the VMAs earlier this week and I know
that you're very picky about the beats
that you choose to work with do you
remember your initial reaction to
hearing that dembo-style Bongos beat for
the first time like did you immediately
recognize its potential to be a hit
um I don't I don't know if I like uh
realized it was like a potential to be a
hit I just as soon as I heard I was like
hey
[Music]
hey like a drum
I I automatically liked it and and um
even with my man's right like even with
my husband like like you know I'll be
I'll be playing him like not every day
but like it's like you know we go to the
studio a lot so it's like oh what you've
been working on what you've been playing
on and then you heard the song he's like
oh this is fire
and then I was really impressed with the
Harry Reid headpieces and their ability
to hold their position you know even in
the face of such intense choreography
what were the conversations like
surrounding hats for the music video
Bongos like it just has a theme that you
could just hear tropical music beach
pool party so is that how can we make
Beach luxurious and that's exactly what
we do honey that's what we're doing like
nothing more luxurious than hats and big
feathers and big everything everything
Grand I love being I'm extra I'm a Libra
I want to smell it angry goat bell
pepper Mr shashido shishito oh and I
like shishito pepper you do yeah I eat
it in Noble all the time okay okay let's
try it
[Music]
I could I could taste the shishito
mm-hmm
a little garlic trips a little bit
she's not spicy
so far
you're good don't worry you're on top of
it toshedo Wings wow creative working
for you
so get up 10 from Invasion privacy is in
my opinion like a top tier kicking off
the album Pure Bar kind of song what in
your mind is the aim or goal of just a
great album intro song
yeah you never really know what the
shishito peppers you know when you eat
them like they can all be like one out
of ten of them kicks you know yeah she's
a little scammer because
see now all of a sudden I feel a little
something Tango in my mouth yeah so um a
lot of people tell me that I should put
my pain my struggle in my music
a lot of my pains and a lot of my
struggles or whatever the crap is going
on I feel like the the masses might not
be able to relate you know what I'm
saying like like the masses might not be
able to relate like it's like oh my gosh
they're tearing a new [__] on Twitter
on me because I said this this and that
the average person is that girl shut up
I got I gotta work up at 7am in the
morning I gotta do this this and that so
it's like I don't really like to make
music like I would normally do an intro
like I would just literally like to make
my intro of everything addressing all
the [__] addressing the [__]
addressing the [__] that I gotta go
through and then and then just the whole
album just be about fun because I like
fun you know what I'm saying I like fun
so I think the first like my intro I
feel like is it should be like just me
popping my [__] part of my [__] and
after that all right let's pop some puss
pop my [__] then pop some puss
[Music]
passion fruit is one of my favorite
fruits
I feel like we're kind of on your
palette a little bit she's cute passion
fruit there we go that's what I was
hoping for
[Music]
eign there we go
see no reason to be nervous cardi you
had this all along
no actually I've seen some clips
I've seen some clips
how would you describe the aesthetic
appeal of Thierry mugler to somebody who
wouldn't know the difference between Tom
Brady and Tom Ford he's just really one
of my favorite favorite designers and
this is like this is a dream like all
right so like a couple of months ago I
saw like a piece of vintage piece that I
wore but I'm like squirting through
Instagram and I see it I'm seeing it and
I'm like wow I really had that on my
body and I started like tearing because
I was like
it's just like such a such a proud
moment that out of anybody in the world
he picked me and he trusted me to put on
a museum piece that means everything's
in me and I'm just so happy that I met
him he was so amazing to me and I cannot
those are the type of things that is
like when I'm old
ER and I have my own grandkids we're
like yeah come yeah because you know
Terry McClure oh he's yeah he be he had
me with his [__] when I wore that thing
so grab me [__] was shook yeah cause
I was a bad [__] I was a bad [__]
[Music]
oh this is this is a good interview
oh I could I could smell it though damn
I could smell everything
okay okay okay
[Music]
what's it like to record uh clean for
radio version of a card
because I just did it like practically
two weeks ago and I was like so over it
because it's like it's like you know
like my new song I'd be like [__] eat
this ass like a plum yeah yeah yeah yeah
so like you know I'm doing the clean
version and it's like all right baby eat
it up like a plum and it's like no they
still you still can play that for pop
radio whatever and I'm like
baby eat these peaches and plums
and I was so over it like it's like I'm
not trying to look up like because I
cannot say that like that is that sounds
so corny like that sounds like a Kidz
Bop whatever my
but I have no choice so baby eat this
baby eat these peaches and plums
[Music]
I've been looking at this it's like what
is this this look like it's very
interesting okay let's try it
what is this honey
[Music]
awesome no it's the first
kind of jump I feel like that was a
little jump
I agree with you yeah
why are you talking about like I agree
with you like you didn't know that this
was good
so it could help but to notice that in
your 73 questions interview with Vogue
you said that you wish people would ask
you about current events more so it
seems like not a week goes by that I
don't see you know a whistleblower
testifying about alien extraterrestrial
material or UFOs and government
cover-ups where are you on that whole
thing like do you have any thoughts on
Aliens and the possibility that they
visited Earth I don't believe the aliens
are real
I really don't believe that aliens are
real because it's like okay so if aliens
are real
and they're smarter than us right
I feel like it's like why they just
haven't invaded us
so aliens if they're smart they know how
humans are humans are like Despicable
they want to take over everything they
just want to have power over everything
and then people be like but why were
aliens
will want to invade Earth Earth is
ghetto they probably they probably they
probably like so Advanced like they
probably they probably think that that
Earth is like a small fry and it's like
it's not about that right it's The Art
of War
I'm following that don't make sense so
it's like if they so smart like people
think that they are they would have been
invading us just so they could just have
us and not
I just know that they ain't real I don't
care I don't care
[Music]
this sounds good whiskey small ghost yes
it sounds good
hmm
[Music]
you're pondering I see some pondering
going on
a little kind of a Sharp hit yeah yeah
oh [__] you caught me
so she's good no wait
[Music]
oh she's back
oh my God
kind of like the taste but the trail it
leaves behind some violence in the trail
that yeah she left some violence behind
celebrate hip-hop 50 there are now so
many different archetypes for what a
legacy rap act can look like from Queen
Latifah to Jay-Z Missy Elliott to NAS
when you look into the crystal ball and
see cardi B in the year 2043 are there
any artists anybody that you look to as
a role model for how you might want to
age or mature as an artist
who I look up to it will be like Jay-Z
Rihanna
because
I just feel like they're they're like
super moguls and I feel like I feel like
my my tongue is drunk I feel like my
tongue is drunk like it's like I'm
trying to say something and it's like I
can't even focus on the [__] question
because it's like that's the show that's
the show for better or worse it was like
what the [__] you asking me my mouth is
hurting
on that note are you ready to move on to
saw seven
this one kind of looks gross so I kind
of Wonder a Tropic star here Ginger
oh she's not gross
[Music]
suspicious look because I know she's
coming
yep I knew she was coming yeah yeah
but she's good
[Music]
I'm torturing myself okay
this is spice all worth it yeah this is
how I imagine my breast milk to taste
like
so as a rap fan I've always been
appreciative of a good esoteric Sports
reference like when you did that nod to
WWF Hall of Famer Jimmy Snuka and the
off the top rope Superfly [__] when you
work in a reference like that is that
like a salute to the person or is it
more about you know finding a name that
fits a particular rhyme scheme or
metaphor
I really wanted to say Triple H
but it didn't right it didn't rhyme so I
just said Jimmy Snuka so I was like yeah
that worked and uh so it's kind of a
little bit of both then yeah because I
was picturing like like on like on top
like jumping like a wrestler like yeah
but I really wanted to say Triple H but
it's like that wouldn't even rhyme like
it's not even going with this floor or
anything so I just said Jimmy snuck up
on the top bro Super Flash [__] and then
as a wrestling fan do have an idea of
like what like the uh wrestling the
Wrestlemania fit for cardi B would be
very skimpy but I got I feel like I I'm
my my entrance have to be like Grand
like what's her name her name was it was
not right Melita or Molina do you
remember her that she used to like walk
in with two guys and then like she would
do like a whole split on the ropes she
would like answer like on a split like I
had to like enter like Grand like that
she was just crazy with that
I'm telling you she looked like a poison
from SpongeBob
splitting that open
oh
oh she stinks
[Music]
oh my God oh my God I'm scared
I'm scared I knew that that would go
that way
never gets any easier for me either by
the way I'm scared I'm scared we're
doing laps
I'm scared let it out okay what can I do
whatever you got to do whatever you
gotta do
you have a lasting memory from taking
David Letterman to get a chopped cheese
sandwich you know as a fan of both Dave
and New York's greatest sandwich it was
quite the cultural moment to witness
okay when does it leave all right when
does the leave my tongue so it's gonna
kind of be like this we're gonna kind of
be in this hot tub I think for a little
bit I know I know
but body it still on top still on top
going for the uh lifelines
when does it stop burning
[Music]
when does it stop
is that the spiciest thing you've ever
eaten um
mm-hmm
oh my gosh when does it stop
it doesn't stop it it doesn't stop
we got some ice cream you want some ice
cream
[Music]
oh my God
all right okay I gotta get I gotta call
my composure which was asking me oh
about uh taking David Letterman to get a
chopped cheese sandwich you know did you
have a lasting memory from that kind of
an amazing cultural moment to witness
I that wasn't even like my favorite part
I didn't really care about that part
what stays in my mind
for a long time is that I went to FDR's
house
if anybody loves me know me I love FDR
you love FDR yes and I love Eleanor
Roosevelt and you know Hawaii got us
through the Great Depression
what a war
only president that got like the fourth
time
while he's in a wheelchair
as I grew up reading a lot about Eleanor
Roosevelt
she had a very sad life
and like when I went to her uh her house
well she she had different house from
her from her husband because you know
um FDR mama she was always around like
and she didn't really like that like
everyone wanted her space just like me I
want my own space all the time
I saw the room where Churchill and FDR
was talking about the nuke
that is crazy to me like like I'm really
here like I like I don't know why I'm
obsessed with war article I could hear
it with the aliens yes it's in you I'm
obsessed with World War II like I love
World War One Like You know I like
reading about that but World War II like
I'm obsessed with just learning
everything about it so for me to be in
the same room that Churchill and FDR was
discussing the nuke is like
it was just such a moment for me like
y'all probably think I'm crazy but like
it was just like
dude I don't know I don't know
oh my God my mouth is not burning
anymore you know that's all it took you
just had to walk down and you know do a
historical re-envisioning of FDR you
know yeah that's all it took all along
we just had to talk some American
history
because I
I don't want more
foreign
but after the last one kind of it like
kind of clears everything out the pain a
little bit right sure
as a rap mom is there a children's book
that stands out to you for having like
the hardest bars like is it llama llama
red pajama
uh
I I love that book episode something I
think about that book I could only I
could only picture my head when like the
Migos was doing it
good memories
I love having good memories of them in
my head
I'm dying yeah I'm dying I know wait
how is this one so this is the last ad
we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last one you don't have to
if you don't want to by the way let me
use yours because mine's is closed sure
I'd be honored here you go cardi get me
ready
oh my gosh
plots like you have just tweezers
it's amazing
[Music]
the face says it all that's all you know
what guardi that is that is good that is
good in the wings of death they're
behind us okay I mean eating is all over
I get it I get it I get it
what does it
it's not even about the spiciness it's
just like the taste of it it just tastes
like heart yeah yeah yeah it's big so to
close things out I love this quote of
yours in a 2017 interview that you did
with Al reacting to Andy warhol's quote
about Fame being art you said to me
music is Art and fashion is Art but fame
fame is an art but the person you become
when you're famous your Alter Ego that's
art how do you think about the
connection between who you are in and
out of the spotlight no cause I'm a
person
[Music]
yeah so it's like you know like
like if something's really spicy I feel
like I can breathe oh [__] why the most
what the [__] the more I talk about it
just burn my mouth
[Music]
um
just wanna go home to my kids I get it
oh
this is crazy
I mean ain't no real difference between
you balconies and cardi B
they both some sensitive ass [__]
um
that's all right that's all right
because cardi you gave it your all today
and it was so much more than we deserved
and now all that's left to do is roll
out the red carpet for you cardi B this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
um
see them
happy that I'm gonna make my fans happy
pain
what
had a good time
and your questions were so amazing and
different because I hate when people ask
me the same [__] you know what I'm
saying thank you
[Music]
I mean who don't love ice cream
[Applause]
thank you
this is crazy oh my God
[Music]
torture
from here do you think it'll be more of
a hot sauce person or less of a hot
sauce person I don't I don't want to see
buffalo wings for a [__] I think
that's fair I think that's fair
hot ones fans it's been years in the
making but at long last the next big
thing in Wings is finally here
introducing hot ones buffalo sauce our
spin on Buffalo is a rich and tangy
combo of cayenne peppers distilled
vinegar and yes real butter which means
that you can put hot ones buffalo sauce
directly on wings no mixing or melting
required it's the best damn buffalo
sauce I've ever had in my life but don't
take my word for it camera guy Bill
Buffalo's favorite song gives it to
blaze and thumbs up don't you Bill
that's a Buffalo Bill guarantee
[Music]
[Applause]
heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
brand new hot ones buffalo sauce
[Music]